the newest addition to the Apple family
and of course I'm talking about the
Apple watch Apple had their spring
forward keynote address on Monday where
they talked about the Apple watch
that'll change your life because you'll
have to declare bankruptcy and the new
MacBook nothing MacBook Pro or the
MacBook Air no no no we're way past that
we're going back in time they're
bringing back the old plastic segregated
MacBook but with some upgrades if you're
broke this video is gonna make you sad
if you have money bearing holes in your
pockets though keep watching and get
ready to write a check for $17,000 you
guys still write checks right I'm Gabe
hole writer and this is hashtag news
let's get down to business the app for
watch I know what you're thinking it's
like a phone but in the form of a watch
right no no this product is not going to
replace your phone in fact it requires
your phone to be very close by at all
times to even work at all
convenience it basically works like this
you're watching your phone or connected
by a Bluetooth so that whenever you
receive a call or an email on your phone
your watch alerts you then using the
watch you can read emails check your
schedule and even answer those phone
calls right from the watch so you can
look like a spy or like a crazy person
shopping for perfume tell mom I won't
make it home for Christmas developers
have already created thousands of apps
including a fitness app that literally
reminds you to stand up I guess that's
what Americans are calling exercise an
app that allows you to unlock your hotel
room door because the best way to get
over your watch being stolen on vacation
is finding out that you're everything
else was also stolen and an app that
controls your garage door you don't have
a garage door I mean either I told you
this video would make us sad the Apple
watch doesn't have a camera and of
course the question that everyone's
asking is how much will this thing cost
well it depends on which type of Apple
watch you get the Apple watch starts at
$349 which is kind of a lot I mean I
thought my iPhone was allows $199 so it
was free upgrade it's like alright yeah
it goes all the way up to 17,000 monies
that's the same price as a 2015 Ford
Fiesta with a brand new MacBook and
iPhone sitting in the passenger seat or
a half an acre of beachfront property in
Nicaragua or one watch that only works
when it's near your film which also
tells time can we see a side-by-side of
the three and a $50 one and the $17,000
one okay well they look basically the
same can we see the extra features you
get with the $17,000 watch what about
all those girls that will suddenly be
interested in you because if you're a
great personality
all right personality a lot so basically
what I'm saying is the Apple watch is
not worth it unless you have a ton of
money to throw around I'd suggest just
buying a cheap calculator watch on eBay
and end all your emails with set for my
Apple watch nobody will know the
difference other announcements at the
keynote included the new MacBook it
comes in gold it weighs two pounds and
only has one connection port thank
goodness having too many ports to plug
things into is a major complaint that
no one was making in an effort to make
the laptop thinner at the trackpad
doesn't actually click anymore but
vibrates to mimic a click can always
count on Apple to innovate amazing ways
to fix things that aren't broken just to
give other devices body image issues
also announced HBO partnered with Apple
to exclusively offer HBO content let's
be honest just Game of Thrones but
without needing a cable or satellite
subscription whoa
shots fired at media conglomerates the
service called HBO now will be $14.99 a
month cash it's a lot of money it's time
for math with Gabe Gabe stop that was
boring alright alright fine fine that's
it for hashtag news subscribe if you
like what we're doing here click the
like button click the favor button pick
comment join the discussion come on
we're a big community here we're having
fun okay all right I gotta catch each
other